was Love Actually on this Christmas
presumably it was it must have been
somewhere yeah here it's a big deal in
America it's an even bigger deal is it
it's I mean massive did I hear a yes
yeah right no it's it's like it's it's
very popular here but in America it's
like a serious business I've been asked
in America if I've ever done anything
else
I do genuinely 20 years people yeah
hello
people came up to me I can't remember
which American airport and said um we
really loved you in Love Actually it was
amazing it's one of our favorite films
have you ever done anything else I was
like why are you little
now you're in London does the Love
Actually reaction get bigger in London
no that's weird we know it's it's sort
of it love actually so much bigger than
I ever thought it would ever be or any
of us did that it it's sort of a
universal
sort of connection that people have with
them well it's turned into a kind of an
annual Christmas movie people watch Love
Actually a Christmas joke yeah yeah yeah
but but people feel sorry for you they
feel very sorry for me but they
shouldn't they shouldn't because I
really believe I got the best kiss in
that movie hands down
okay sorry who's that with you Rodrigo
Santoro oh yeah
[Applause]
I mean whooping for him yeah wait wait
and it was sweet because we were both
very broken-hearted when we made that
movie he had just been dumped I had just
been dumped and I remember the day we
were gonna go shoot this and we both
sort of slumped in the van
broke and I was like
it turned him I was like well all day
long we get to make each other feel
better
I think there is a sweetness to the
scene because of that we were both we
were both very safe Sweet let's all
watch it again now now we mentioned the
two of you working together you and Emma
uh obviously brother and sister in Love
Actually which I sort of you forget that
your brother and sister in that movie
and then lovers in Sense and Sensibility
beautiful
oh
he was so grumpy
so grumpy he knew me he'd known me for
years there was nothing there for him he
knew that I wasn't gonna cough up
the other thing we noticed about the two
of you because there are pictures of you
uh doing a red carpet together in the
various films you've done and it seems
to me you're a very different
um red carpet
approaches approaches so here's here's a
picture of the two of you uh on the red
carpet now yeah you looking very
Debonair and studied slightly appalled
and then you
chocolate a red carpet doesn't seem to
send you slightly Bonkers yeah that's
not my natural habitat you know it's
like you came up with photobombing I
mean here's Will Ferrell and his lovely
wife they're on the red carpet looking
perfectly Pleasant and then right behind
them
[Applause]
so good
but regarding me people you know because
even new stars new stars just just
coming blinking into the spotlight just
kind of it's award season finally this
is my moment here is Lupita Nyong'o
me it's her first red carpet you're
doing it she's done 18 red carpets by
the time we were on that one she was
relieved believe me you'd do anything
for a laugh by then Nina you had the
thrill of being one of the biggest
Christmas movies of all time uh Love
Actually playing Hugh grants it was
Private secretary
[Applause]
and that's evil isn't it annoyingly
Untouched by time
Hugh Grant looks like a Schoolboy
you look exactly the same that's just
because I haven't changed my hair for 30
years or something yeah that's his
mistake but you you didn't get how big
this film kind of remains no I had no
idea maybe I just don't watch Telly at
Christmas but
um I had no idea it was showing every
year
because I don't get a check every year
reminded
yeah but presumably people come up to
you about it oh yeah and I've realized
recently I was uh filming
killing Eve I think it was and there was
a a youngish man I thought he was just
sort of you know my age but clearly not
um and he we'd been filming for quite a
while and then we were sat sort of
somewhere something like this and he was
sort of
looking at me and going can I can I just
say uh that it's just really weird
sitting next to you because you're in my
house every Christmas and I've grown up
with you on grown up with
screen on Christmas day and even if they
didn't put the sound up it's on it's
just on I'm in his living room and have
been since he can ever since you can
remember which is Warrior
two in the red chair so uh who's up
first who's up first
is this like one of those things okay
okay off you go off you go
[Applause]
you didn't know him did you yeah he was
my husband
we all want to know what was on those
cards oh all I know is in French drew
the word tosser
foreign
it was not meant to be sexy it was meant
to be kind of innocent and so it wasn't
that um you know when you do sex scenes
that are where you are giving that you
know when you're when you're acting that
that's a little bit more vulnerable
making I mean it's a bit more because
you know inevitably you're kind of
giving away some of your own State
Secrets there you know
um
it was dialogue you know it was like the
funny bit about it was that it was two
very Ordinary People it wasn't meant to
be turning anyone on you know okay so if
it did
oh
I wasn't expecting to see that
I'm naked at other podcasts yeah yeah
we're not fully naked you get a little
purse
you get a little person a change purse
yeah yeah and it's um
and the woman gets a strip yeah maybe
some but sometimes are you working for
us
ually when I uh you know introduce the
character do you all know each other uh
but now Timmy you and I bit Gooseberry
because this is I think the first time
we've ever had this that you guys you
dated at one point yeah Helen and I yes
oh yes yes
we didn't date we lived together
four years yeah we were a a serious item
for a while yeah but I remember Karen
Hines and myself we did this film
Excalibur together yeah 1980 the first
movie for all of us really that was it
really it was so we were so green and
ignorant about filmmaking but I remember
being out of the set this was Ardmore
Studios oh yeah Dublin and uh
Helen had a break she was filming but
she was in costume and we were there
just visiting we hadn't started work yet
and uh the first idea of the second ID
said would you like to meet Helen mirror
and said yeah I would love to so she
walked from like a hundred yards away
dressed and as Morgana Le Faye
and Cairns my oldest friend and we both
[__]
so I was smitten thank you Miss Mente I
was certainly you thought you've never
told me that before that's amazing oh